Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Selon le WWF,
la Méditerranée est aujourd’hui l’une
des mers les plus polluées du monde.
À chaque seconde, on y rejette plus
de huit kilos de déchets plastiques.
Au rythme actuel, si rien n’est fait,
il y aura plus de plastiques
que de poissons en mer d’ici 2050.
Est-ce une fatalité ?
Pour moi, la réponse est non,
même si les solutions actuelles
ont montré leurs limites.
On peut récupérer les déchets
qui sont éparpillés en mer à la surface,
mais c'est peu efficace et fort coûteux.
On peut aussi récupérer les déchets
à l’embouchure des dix
principaux fleuves du monde.
Seulement, ça ne représente que 1%
de la pollution plastique en mer,
autant dire une goutte d’eau dans l’océan.
Enfin, on peut interdire la vente
de produits plastiques à usage unique.
C'est une bonne chose.
Mais dans le même temps,
notre consommation de masques, de gants
et de lingettes ne cesse d’augmenter.
Alors, que faire ?
Je vous propose tout d'abord
de changer de paradigme.
Lorsque vous voulez vider votre baignoire,
vous commencez par fermer son robinet.
La solution se trouve
où se concentrent les déchets,
car 80% des déchets qui sont
dans la mer proviennent de la terre.
Il faut donc intervenir
là où ils se concentrent
avant qu’ils ne s’éparpillent
en mer, à l’interface ville-mer.
Je suis scaphandrière professionnelle
et fondatrice de la start-up
Green City Organisation.
Notre métier,
c’est de concevoir des solutions
de veille et de protection de la mer.
Mon équipe et moi,
on connaît particulièrement bien
le problème de la pollution marine
car nous la constatons
à chacune de nos immersions.
Lors des épisodes pluvieux importants,
les villes littorales rejettent
directement à la mer et sans traitement
les eaux de pluie chargées en déchets
via ce qu’on appelle des exutoires,
donc de gros tuyaux
qui se déversent en mer.
Ce sont tous les déchets qui jonchent
les rues, les trottoirs et les caniveaux,
qui, en l’espace de quelques heures,
vont être directement rejetés
à la mer sans traitement,
telle une véritable chasse d’eau.
On a donc conçu une solution innovante
car en rupture avec les solutions
actuelles qui récupèrent les déchets
alors qu’ils sont déjà éparpillés
en mer ou sur terre.
Notre solution est efficace,
intelligente et pragmatique.
Efficace parce qu’elle capte les déchets
de la taille d’un mégot de cigarette
là où ils se concentrent, à la sortie
des réseaux d’eaux pluviales,
grâce à une collerette qui permet
de fixer un filet à l’exutoire,
exutoire qui peut être
terrestre ou sous-marin.
Intelligente, car notre dispositif
est monitoré en temps réel.
Il nous alerte donc automatiquement
lorsque le filet est plein
et qu’il faut intervenir pour le vider.
Le système permet également
de collecter tout un tas de données
et transforme un simple exutoire
en une véritable station de mesure
de la qualité de l’eau.
On peut ainsi collecter des données
sur la température,
la salinité, la turbidité, l’acidité
ou le taux d’oxygène dans l’eau.
Pragmatique,
car notre solution est conçue pour pouvoir
être fabriquée partout dans le monde,
quel que soit l’outil
de production disponible.
On peut ainsi répondre à la demande
de toutes les villes littorales
en privilégiant les circuits courts.
Pour booster notre développement
en Méditerranée,
nous mutualisons les savoir-faire
de telle sorte à ce qu’on puisse
accélérer l’impact de nos actions.
Ainsi, nous nouons des partenariats
avec des ONG environnementales.
Elles partagent avec nous les mêmes
valeurs et le même engagement
pour la préservation de la mer.
Grâce à leur implantation locale solide,
nous pouvons faire connaître notre
solution auprès des décideurs locaux.
Les ONG, quant à elles, peuvent
s’appuyer sur notre dispositif
pour sensibiliser le grand public
à la problématique des rejets en mer,
mais aussi à valoriser certains métiers
tels que celui de chiffonnier,
le véritable expert
dans le domaine du tri,
et ainsi conforter
la filière locale du recyclage.
[En 2021],
nous avons signé deux conventions,
l’une avec la Fondation Pro Biome
en Algérie
et une avec Surfrider Foundation au Maroc.
Notre objectif d’ici fin [2022]
est d’avoir un partenaire associatif dans
les 21 pays du pourtour méditerranéen.
Il est donc important
que nous puissions bénéficier
de la participation de tous les pays
riverains de la Méditerranée
pour pouvoir demain et durablement
protéger la mer.
Nous avons la conviction
qu’il est de notre responsabilité
de léguer aux générations futures
des océans préservés.
C’est notre priorité
et nous y mettons toute notre énergie.
Car aujourd'hui, il y a urgence
à se retrousser les manches.
Chacun d’entre nous
peut être l’ambassadeur
de solutions pratiques et efficaces.
Mais il faut garder à l’esprit
que le meilleur des déchets,
c’est celui que l'on ne produit pas.
Pour terminer, j’aimerais vous partager
une citation de Baudelaire
qui m’inspire particulièrement
et que j’ai reprise un peu à ma façon :
« Femme libre,
toujours tu chériras la mer. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)